christa neu merkel geht auch mit ihren
86 jahren noch ungewöhnliche wege auf
dem dresdner jugendherbergs schiff an
der elbe trifft sie die
konfirmandengruppe von pfarrer
schwarzenberg aus großröhrsdorf am 75
jahrestag der bombardierung dresdens
erzählt die zeitzeugin was sie als
elfjährige durchgemacht hat die zuhörer
heute sind nur wenig älter als ihr haus
von einer bombe getroffen wird ist die
kleine kristall ein im luftschutzkeller
bei den nachbarn
die hatten auch eine große schwester und
die tauchte plötzlich auf die hat gesagt
wir müssen hier raus unser haus hier
fängt an zu brennen ja müssen
wenn dir und sich festgehalten hätte
wären wir dort ins feuer getrieben
worden
ihr habt das ist nicht schön und auch
gesehen empfiehlt vor dem feuersturm
gehört in jener nacht legen hunderte
britische bomber dresden in schutt und
asche bis zu 25.000 menschen sterben im
flammeninferno
das wird schon 1945 amtlich festgestellt
die nazi propaganda fällt die zahl auf
250.000 dresden führt zu unschuldigen
märtyrer stadt hoch stilisiert das
empört christian oertel
auch wenn sie bis heute mit den opfern
leidet
der krebs ist von deutschland
ausgegangen
wer als einzelperson braucht nicht
schuld zu sein aber als wahrscheinlich
und die resolute alte dame legt nach wer
heute leid und verbrechen der nazi zeit
relativiere habe nichts verstanden und
nichts gelernt was mich aber am meisten
bedrückt ist dass es schon wieder leute
gibt die das euch wie hat der gaul hat
gesagt entriss der geschichte also ich
verstehe das einfach nicht dafür man so
sagen kann ja auch keine juncker hält
das auch noch erleben die jugendlichen
sind beeindruckt in ihrer heilen welt
kamen die gräuel des krieges noch nicht
vor man kann sich das nicht vorstellen
dass es mal wirklich so gewesen ist und
auch für so menschen gewesen ist und ich
nehme mir mit dass man mehr darüber
nachdenkt und sich auch klar macht wie
schlimm das gewesen sein muss und dass
es nicht nochmal passiert ich finde es
einfach den mut zu haben
durch das feuer zu laufen dann überhaupt
noch kraft zu haben das alles mit zu
erleben und dann auch noch wiederzugeben
vor so vielen menschen dann christian
merkel will weiter umtriebig zeugnis
ablegen auch wenn sie manchmal zweifelt
was sie allein bewirken kann
aber wir müssen es immer wieder
versuchen
wie heißt es so schön die hoffnung
stirbt zuletzt und deshalb hat sie dem
fahrer beim abschied zugesagt dass sie
nächstes jahr wieder kommt